cette histoire commence en 1997 quand
cette biologiste janine benyus
américaine entreprend de partir à la
rencontre d'un type de chercheurs un peu
particulier des chercheurs qui
s'intéressent chacun dans leur domaine
informatique l'agronomie la chimie à
trouver des solutions dans le vivant
pour innover de façon écologique donc
guiliano vous présenter trois
différentes solutions issues de son
ouvrage qui vous montrer le potentiel du
vivant pour changer notre industrie
alors le vivant bas c'est déjà un
designer vraiment incroyable donc il est
capable de faire plein de choses et
notamment de produire de fabriquer des
copies beaucoup plus résistante que les
plus robustes des céramiques nous sommes
aujourd'hui capables de créer et ça il
le fait déjà dans l'eau de mer
ensuite un autre exemple il est capable
de créer des fibres qui sont beaucoup
plus résistantes et élastique au moins
cinq fois plus résistante que l'acier
et ça il le fait à partir de composés
organiques bénin et enfin dernier
exemple pour une autre corde production
donc lhi capable de produire des
panneaux photovoltaïques auto assemblée
biodégradables dont la matière première
n'a pas parcouru plus de quelques mètres
alors là où l'industrie traditionnelle
utilise de très hautes températures de
très haute pression utilise londres en
tant que solvant pour produire nos
objets du quotidien et bien le
biologique le vivant 8le fait la même
chose de façon beaucoup plus performante
mais en utilisant l'eau comme solvant
l'étape des températures ambiantes
dépression ambiante et des ressources
localement disponibles alors musc et moi
avons été fouillé un petit peu dans le
vivant pour vous donner quelques
exemples de stratégies ou de principes
de fonction de mécanismes intéressant et
là on va vous parlait déjà dans un
premier temps de la tortue lors la
tortue l allaine nageoires assez
particulière qui est vraiment incroyable
donc elle a une vascularisation une
vascularisation qu'elle peut mettre en
mode homme ou à foix lorsque l'eau est
chaude
elle va donc activer son mât de
vascularisation récupérer la chaleur
pourra transférer à son corps et lorsque
l'eau va être quoi elle va stopper cette
vascularisation pour conserver la
température interne autre source
d'inspiration le tournesol
on a tous l'image du tournesol qui va
suivre le soleil tout au long de la
journée
la même façon on pourrait être intéressé
à avoir un système analogue sur nos
panneaux solaires qui actuellement pour
la plupart sont fixes qui pourraient
ainsi optimiser l'énergie qui vont
capter tout au long de la journée
là on va passer au niveau des insectes
alors peut-être certains d'entre vous
connaissent le bombardier le bombardier
ces insectes qui est juste incroyable
donc lille de développer une stratégie
pour faire face à ces prédateurs dont il
est capable de faire bouillir de l'eau
de façon quasi instantanée par une
réaction chimique qui produit dans son
corps et on y va faire bouillir cette
eau et l'expulsé directement sur ces
prédateurs pour les faire fuir
changeant d'échelle passons des
organismes aux écosystèmes dans les
écosystèmes mais aussi énormément de
principes qui peuvent être intéressants
notamment par exemple qu'un certain
nombre d organismes vivent exclusivement
sur les déchets des autres organismes de
l'écosystème ça peut nous inspirer pour
réorganiser la façon dont la matière
circulent dans nos régions la thermique
le thermique le thermique est donc un
insecte aussi qui lui a un habitat assez
particulier du point de vue thermique
en fait c'est un système de cheminée à
l'intérieur de l'habitat qui lui permet
de réguler sa température au degré près
alors que dans son environnement
désertique
la température varie de 40 degrés donc
on a vraiment un système thermique
complètement passif très très bien
optimisé
là on va passer un exemple des milieux
marins
le nautile alors l'outil je pense que
certains retrouvent le corps ne le
connaissait cette espèce donc il a un
fonctionnement un peu particulier
lorsque vous faites une coupe vous voyez
une structure particulière donc l'effet
de ballast ce sont des petites chambres
qu'il à venir remplir plus ou moins pour
pouvoir comme les sous-marins finalement
descendre dans les profondeurs et
expulsé l'eau qui leur a accumulé dans
cette chambre là pour remonter à la
surface
l'ours polaire aussi intéressant du
point de vue de l'isolation cette fois
ci puisque sa température corporelle est
à peu près similaire à la nôtre mais qui
vit dans des environnements beaucoup
beaucoup plus froid comment fait-il et
bien sa fourrure est assez spécifique
elle a des poils de différentes
longueurs et creux qui emprisonne de
manière très très stable une couche
d'air à la surface de la peau qui permet
ainsi de l'isoler du froid extérieur et
enfin on va vous parler aussi un peu du
toucan alors le toucan si vous faites
une coupe de son bec vous le coupé à la
scie comme ça vous allez voir qu'ils
disposent d'une structure qui est
vraiment super intéressante donc une
structure alvéolaire l'intérieur qui lui
permet d'une part d'avoir un mec
extrêmement rigide d'avoir un mec très
léger et en même temps d'avoir une très
très bonne isolation thermique donc en
gros dans la structure il ya des poches
d'air qu'il conserve près de son corps
pour conserver la chaleur donc admettons
que dans toutes les inspirations
convient de vous mentionner on en a
sélectionné quatre donc la première le
termite on a également sélectionné le
nautile l'ours polaire
et enfin le toucan
sur la base de ces quatre inspiration
quel objet pourrions nous inventer un
premier éventuellement se serait
peut-être un module de climatisation
ultra léger résistant inspiré de la
termitière et du toucan ou bah oui
j'aurais plutôt dit un sous marin pour
l'exploration polaire donc en nous
inspirant du nautile et de l'ours
polaire
la réponse est beaucoup moins romantique
il s'agit d'une bouilloire alors
pourquoi une bouilloire et bien en fait
derrière cet objet qu'on a tous dans nos
maisons se cache un certain nombre de
problématiques écologiques importantes
la production énergétique dans un
premier temps qui fuit une problématique
notamment au niveau de l'électricité est
assez importante
deuxième élément les matériaux le
plastique les métaux l'électronique
éventuellement dans certains modèles
troisième la gestion de l'eau on veut
parler d'écologie on veut éco concevoir
des objets donc la bouilloire et une
bonne étude de cas pour montrer qu'avec
le vivant on peut innover dans ce sens
là alors on a déjà commencé par réaliser
aucune étude autour de l'objet
bouilloire et on s'est rendu compte que
80% de l'impact environnemental de cet
objet là est liée à la consommation
électrique en face du zoo alors en face
du zoo
chez nous quand même très très bonne
nouvelle pour un designer est pour un
bus ingénieurs et donc on sait on a
observé les usages et on s'est rendu
compte de plusieurs problèmes
et là on s'est dit ok on utilise de
l'eau de l'énergie en très grande
quantité pour chauffer cet os on va donc
chercher à optimiser la chauffe on
chauffe également trop d'eau donc on va
tous chauffer un demi litre ou un litre
d'eau pour la chauffer qu'une tu as
finalement on le fait tout ça on va donc
chercher à contrôler le volume d'eau
ensuite on chauffe systématiquement à
son degré c'est un de nos grands travers
alors que la plus la température idéale
de la plupart de boissons se situe entre
60 à 70 degrés à peu près on va donc
chercher à contrôler la température de
l'eau et enfin on retrouve fréquemment
le 2ème volume donc on a tous laissez
refroidir sa bouilloire avant de se
rendre compte que c'était faux mais on
relance une deuxième chauffe
on va donc chercher à isoler ce volume
d'eau pour le garder chaud le plus
longtemps possible
sur la base de ce nouveau cahier des
charges nous allons donc explorer les
différentes stratégies qu'offrent les
espèces vivantes ils différentes
stratégies qu'elles ont déjà en fête
mise en oeuvre pour résoudre ce cahier
des charges donc on a été voir comme
vous l'avez vu chez les reptiles chez
les insectes chez les micro-organismes
chez les mammifères et est donc à partir
de tout ça on s'est donc inspiré des
principes des fonctions des mécanismes
du vivant de ses formes la façon dont
elle produit dont le fabriquent les
choses et on a généré une centaine de
concept en allant voir chez les
mammifères comment ils font pour isoler
par exemple chez les espèces marines
chez les végétaux ce genre de choses
donc on est passé beaucoup beaucoup de
choses en revue et malheureusement sur
cette centaine de concept c'est une
poignée en fait était vraiment utile
pour deux raisons principales
une qu'on a déjà mentionné en amont qui
est le fait que
les systèmes vivants sont beaucoup
énormément en avance sur notre industrie
en termes de production écologique
c'est à dire que souvent quand vous
voulez serez inspiré d'un système vivant
qui nous semblait intéressant quand on
transposait dans nos procédés
industriels
on perdait tous les avantages qu'on
avait en termes d'impact environnemental
donc on a dû en éliminer énormément à
cause de ça et deuxième solution
deuxième problématique c'était le fait
que du point de vue de l'usager
quelques-unes de ses solutions était
très compliquée à mettre en oeuvre aussi
on aurait dû passer beaucoup plus de
temps
chauffer notre eau que pendant une
fenêtre de cinq minutes par jour on a le
soleil qui passe par la fenêtre tout un
tas problématique de ce type là donc au
final on n'avait qu'une poignée de
solutions qui nous ont donné l'objet
final
alors lorsque vous voyez maintenant
c'est une coupe donc on a fait une
section de l'objet pour vous montrer un
petit peu comment ça fonctionne et
comment on a pu s'inspirer du vivant
pour reconcevoir l'objet bouilloire
alors dans un premier temps ce que vous
voyez les sphères les quatre sphères
comme ça que vous voyez c'est
l'inspiration du nautile on va donc par
ce moyen là chercher à contrôler le
volume d'eau donc sur le principe du
nautile on voit bien qu'on a des sphères
comme ça corresponde tout au volume
d'une tonne chacune et avec un petit
bouchon sur la partie supérieure on va
venir
le pivot tu es sélectionné si on veut
remplir une tasse de tasses qantas ou 4
tasses et donc ouvrir des vannes à
l'intérieur qui vont remplir ses se
faire à l'intérieur pour le chauffer que
ce dont on a besoin
alors pourquoi la sphère la sphère parce
que c'est la forme optimale pour limiter
les pertes de chaleur
ensuite pour contrôler la tempête les
opérateurs de l'eau n'a mis au point une
petite pièce métallique qui se déforme
en fonction de la température de l'eau
et du coup va stopper de façon mécanique
et du coup sans électronique
la chauffe de l'eau une fois qu'elle
arrivait à température désirée
parlons de la termitière maintenant
alors la termitière on à réguler le flux
thermiques et à l'intérieur de cette
bouilloire en créant ce que vous voyez
au centre donc cette espèce de cheminée
qui est irriguée par de très nombreux
canaux qui ont été rendues possibles
grâce à aux techniques de l'impression
3d parce que c'était voulu à imprimer en
3d donc c'est de l'argile qui est
imprimé et donc on va chauffer à la fois
par l'intérieur et par l'extérieur donc
dans la matière également
pour ce qui est de garder l'eau chaude
le plus longtemps possible là on avait
deux inspirations et et l'ours polaire
et le toucan don bosco vous voyez autour
on a conçu une structure qui permet à
l'objet à la fois léger très rigide et
en même temps de voir une très loin de
l'isolation sur l'extérieur et en
surface à on les voit pas parce qu'ils
sont très très petit ont des tas de
petits picots creux qui reprennent le
principe de l'ours polaire qui
permettent d'isoler encore le liquide
chaud de l'intérieur avec l'extérieur de
l'objet alors pour le scénario du sage
il n'y a rien de plus simple
donc on va d'abord sélectionner le
nombre de ça ce qu'on va chercher à
remplir en faisant pivoter le bouchon on
va ensuite du coup verser du liquide à
l'intérieur et on a une petite base et
expliqué simon à une version également à
combustion pour sélectionner la
température désirée
on pose la bouilloire dessus elle
s'arrête de chauffer automatiquement il
faut arriver à la température voulue
voilà c'est simple c'est une fois que
ces prêts concert alors moi je suis
designer et je m'intéressais déjà vu
mutisme depuis un moment et je me suis
dit bon d'accord c'est super intéressant
d'aller creuser le vivant d'aller
explorer le vivant pour en découvrir de
nouveaux principes qu'on pouvait
transférer de l'environnement naturel à
l'environnement humain mais il me
manquait des outils déjà les outils pour
aller fouiller dans le vivant voilà des
je n'avais pas ça avec moi et des
compétences qui me permettait d qui
m'aurait permis d'évaluer en fait le
tout les tous les concepts toutes les
solutions proposées et dans ce sens
j'avais vraiment besoin de m'associer à
bout de compétences c'était celle de la
bioingénierie donc celle de 1000 cas on
ma part en tant qu'ingénieur j'avais
vivent beaucoup technologie très
intéressante mais qui ne sortaient
jamais du laboratoire à défaut de
trouver des utilisateurs
le succès d'une technologie étant le
moment où elle passe la porte et qu'elle
sert à vraiment un impact social et du
coup pour moi c'était important de
trouver avec travailler avec liliane
pour pouvoir justement passé ce pont
vers l'utilisateur et avoir un réel
impact social et écologique avec avec
des technologies innovantes
alors pour pour conclure donc nous avons
co écrit un cahier de laboratoire
pendant toute la durée du projet c'était
une sorte de journal intime de travail
quelque part qui résumait les avancées
depuis ingénérie des avancées du design
et finalement c'est devenu une sorte d'
ouvrage qui recense deux énormément de
pistes pour concevoir ou concevoir des
objets de façon biomimétique ou bio
inspirée et si le coeur vous en dit vous
invitons à le lire sur le site
issus les librement accessibles moi ce
qui me touchent réellement dans l'
approche biomimétique sait qu'on a un
aspect très liés à l'écologie non
compense durabilité parce que le vivant
à des solutions pour ça mais en même
temps si on n'est pas que sur le plan
écologique on est sur le plan de
l'innovation également le vivant à
développer d'innombrables stratégie le
principe ou de fonction au mécanisme
qu'on peut transférer dans le vivant
dans leur environnement humain pour
concevoir des choses nouvelles et
innovantes et en saas est un puits
inépuisable de solutions nouvelles pour
faire des choses nouvelles et en saas et
le multi est une graine de changement
merci merci